49.7.
>> AND THE STRONGEST SHOOTER IN
THE COMPETITION, HANDS DOWN.
SHOT THAT WITH EASE RIGHT THERE.
>> HE LOOKED LIKE HE COULD HAVE
STEPPED BACK A COUPLE MORE STEPS
AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN GOOD.
>> TYRESE AND DESMOND DOING IT
IN 39.1.
AND THIS IS THE LAST CHANCE.
SCOTTIE BARNES AND TYRESE MAXEY.
WOW, THAT ONE FAN IS REALLY
EXCITED.
SCOTT WEE BARNES.
CAN'T -- OUR FIRST MISS OF THE
MAGIC SHOT.
MAXEY.
CAN'T GET IT.
SCOTTIE, COME ON.
>> OH, COME ON, COME ON SCOTTIE.
>> OH, NO.
OH, HERE COME THE MEMES.
DON'T DO IT AGAIN.
>> OH.
>> OH, NO!
>> COME ON, SCOTTIE, THAT'S
THREE LAYUPS.
>> HOUSE OF HIGHLIGHTS FIRED UP.
DON'T MAKE IT FOUR.
DON'T DO IT.
>> COME ON.
NO WAY.
>> OH, NO.
>> NO WAY --
>> OH!
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS RIGHT NOW?
AND THEN HE HITS THAT ONE.
>> AND THEN MAXEY.
0 FOR 6 ON THE MAGIC.
>> THEY CAN'T BE SERIES.
>> COME ON, THEY TROLLING.
>> THE BALL IS TIPPED.
AND THAT WILL BE A HIGHLIGHT
THAT WE WILL REMEMBER FOR A LONG
TIME AS MAXEY AND BARNES HUGGET
OUT AFTER GOING 0 FOR 6 FROM THE
MAGIC SPOT.
>> THAT MIGHT BE A SHAQ TO THE
FOOL.
>> COME ON.
>> SCOTTIE BARNES'S DEFENSE,
THOUGH, HE DID HAVE SOME TRAVEL
PROBLEMS GETTING HERE.
>> YES, YES.
>> HE MIGHT BE JET LAGGED A
LITTLE BIT.
>> YES, HE JUST GOT HERE TODAY.
>> TODAY?
A FEW HOURSA.
>> HOURS AGO.
>> EVEN MORE OF AN EXCUSE.
>> WOW.
SO THOSE ARE YOUR CHAMPIONS.
TYRESE HALIBURTON, DESMOND BAN